Today we will continue talking about
reinforcement learning.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> maybe first let's start with a bit of a
recap uh from from last week, right? So
last week we introduced first like some
exact methods like value iteration,
policy iteration, uh Q-iteration,
very kind of like beautiful algorithms
uh with guaranteed convergence by the
Bellman contraction,
but as we discussed then you know they
assume that you have a dynamics model
which we don't often in robotics.
Uh then we move to
like tabular RL like Q-learning and
SARSA um
to start learning from experience
towards like model-free models.
Uh and then we also discussed kind of
how we can
uh scale this up to robotics with
continuous images and continuous action
spaces
with like starting from DQN and and then
towards uh DDPG and
uh [clears throat]
cross-entropy methods and so forth,
right?
Uh and so essentially these were all
like the key innovations there and this
last bit
that is like the deep RL part uh
centered around different ways how to
solve this uh like argmax in different
ways.
So everything we looked at last time was
value-based, right? So the idea being um
that we try to learn the worth of every
possible action uh and then you know in
in in a specific state and then we kind
of try to
do the argmax to extract the policy.
Uh and we saw that you know it's a
little bit
difficult to scale this to continuous
sorry to high-dimensional spaces,
right?
So the question we're going to ask today
is like, what if we skip this and
instead of learning a value function and
deriving a policy from it, uh why not
just, you know, since we care about the
the policy itself, uh why not just like
parameterize our policy and um you know,
uh
wiggle the the the neural networks of
our net of our of our network uh to
produce uh behaviors that will achieve
high rewards directly.
Right?
Um so, trying to make um you know, uh
our network produce actions that will
lead to uh higher rewards in the future.
So,
um
to wrap up our recap, um here is the
math from also from last time to kind of
like see where we are starting from. You
know, this is the standard RL objective
uh that you've seen in the last couple
of lectures.
Um
we are just trying to reward uh to
maximize the rewards um as usual. Um we
use a discount factor uh to tell um to
to trade off the uh rewards from today
versus the ones from tomorrow. Um and
then uh because the world is stochastic,
we uh don't um uh we can't optimize with
a single trajectory, but we optimize
expected uh returns.
Um
all right. Uh and finally, our
trajectory dis- distribution um uh to
recap is is this one. So, it's the three
things multiplied together, uh where you
start, what is your initial state
distribution, uh then at each time step,
the probability of your policy uh
uh that assigns to your actions uh
taken, and plus the uh sorry, multiplied
by your environment's transition
probability.
Okay. So, let's say okay, that we are
starting to uh parameterize our policy,
right? Uh and With theta and we want to
first understand how good it is,
right? Because we cannot just like
inspect our network weights to to
determine this.
So and this diagram here like captures
this intuition, right? So
from the same [clears throat] start
date, like some trajectories
are good, some are like kind of middle
and some are bad. And now
obviously we want to our policy to
produce a put more probability to the
good ones, right? Now the the catch is
here that we cannot calculate this
expectation analytically because we
don't know the true distribution over
all robot movements in the real world.
And so we kind of already prefaced this
a little bit in the in the last lecture,
but in practice what we use is something
we call Monte Carlo sampling.
So we we run our robot like n times
using our current policy P theta.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> collect those trajectories and calculate
a
average reward. And
the
kind of like we are making like an
assumption here that
that is maybe like not obvious, but we
are making the assumption that all these
data that we collect are coming from our
current policy. So this is really what
we mean by this is like an on policy
method. So we cannot use like past data
to do this.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so exactly. So we evaluate this
expectation which is a function of our
policy by rolling out our policy
multiple times,
observe the reward and then average it
to estimate how good
our policy is.
Okay.
So we we can evaluate this now with this
Monte Carlo samples, but uh
of course the the main thing is we want
to improve like our policy, right?
How do we do this? So we need to
estimate a gradient for this.
So
our goal is to maximize the expected sum
of rewards
J theta and the trajectories are being
drawn from distribution pi theta tau.
But there [clears throat] is this
problem that we cannot like it's not
straightforward to get a gradient on J
theta directly
because there is this sampling process
in between, right? So the relationship
between both is kind of like implicit.
So this means that, you know, we cannot
simply differentiate through the robot
moving in the in the real world. As they
depend on the dynamics of the world
which we don't actually know.
So
what can we do about this?
So we can do a little bit of math
>> [clears throat]
>> where we can start by writing this
expectation as an integral. So an
integral of pi theta of tau times R of
tau d tau.
Now due to this
integral being a linear operation
we can now bring
the [snorts] gradient inside
the integral.
And now, you know, you might think like
well, this doesn't seem to help us that
much yet, right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Doesn't seem so useful.
But because we still have this
high-dimensional integral
that we really want to avoid to to try
to compute directly
as and we still have
this kind of unknown probability inside.
But now there is kind of like a
elegant trick
of what we can do with this to
put rewrite this into a form that we can
um
have it a bit more useful.
So as I said, right? The integral here
is not yet an expectation because
you can't estimate it by sampling
trajectories
as you have a density gradient not a
density.
So, [clears throat]
as I mentioned there is this this policy
gradient theorem
that allows us to rewrite this into a
more useful form and we will do like
this kind of derivation a little bit
here.
So for this we use this
what is called like the log derivative
trick.
So,
if you remember the
derivative of a log is one over and then
with the chain rule we can
get this very nice identity on the top
right.
>> [snorts]
>> And
Yes, and so here if you look at this
identity over here we can see that the
pi theta of tau times log theta
>> [clears throat]
>> of pi theta divided by theta tau
you can cancel this out
to get grad theta of
pi theta tau. And so here essentially
what we have done is just like we have
multiplied and divided uh
by pi theta tau.
So essentially this means you're just
multiplying by one.
And now we you can substitute this
uh
grad theta of pi theta tau the blue part
back into our original formula.
And now this
starts to to become kind of like a bit
more useful.
Um
Because now what we can do is we can
write this as an expectation of
grad log pi theta of tau times r
of tau
and this is now something more useful
because we can evaluate this expectation
with samples, right?
And we have um
um here now
kind of still this this term inside
um
that is not pi of
a given s, right? So, we don't still
have like the our kind of policy
function. But we will get here in a
second.
Um
>> [snorts]
>> Maybe looking at this
um
Yeah, maybe you might you might look at
this kind of like first part of the
derivation and you might be saying like,
"Well, okay, like
we have now this expectation
over here.
But we are still kind of sampling,
right?
You know, like I just said like a slide
ago that
you know, we can't differentiate
like get the gradient through through
this sampling process, right?
Because
but the the
why this is helping us for now is that
the difference is that now theta appears
inside the expectation. So, we can't
still differentiate through the
sampling, that's correct, but we will be
able to differentiate with respect to
theta.
If you remember also like the slides
from last week
on the smoothness of of theta
despite having non-differentiable reward
functions, for example, with the car
driving through the mountain road.
Exactly. So, we can sample
this term. Here it's kind of a bit more
clear. And that term the second term is
still not differentiable, but
through the sampling, right?
Okay.
So, now we have this this term over
here. This log p theta of of tau term.
And
maybe like here on the top I've I've
written again like the original
formula for the trajectory distribution
we just covered in the recap, right?
So what can we do about this?
So you might remember that
the logarithm of a product
is the sum of its logarithms. So if we
apply it to the formula on both sides,
we can get that we can write now this
log pi of tau as the sum
as the sum of log P of tau
of S zero plus the summation from
T equals one to capital T so over all
the horizon of the log probabilities
under the
policy
of um
plus the log so under the policy plus
the the log of the transition
probabilities.
Now we can substitute this
back to our
policy gradient formula,
right? And we can you know when we have
like the gradient of this,
right? And so if we look at the the
first term, the log of S zero, this
doesn't depend on theta. So we can
cancel this out. And if we look at the
transition probability, this also
doesn't depend on theta. So the gradient
of it we can also cancel out.
Right?
Cool. So after this simplification, the
only terms left are
the log pi theta at T
>> [clears throat]
>> log log pi theta
at given ST terms.
Which are the ones that we actually can
evaluate. So I mean we also don't have
the transition dynamics, right? So it's
good that we can cancel it out.
And so this essentially now gives the
vanilla policy gradient uh formulation.
And we can now sample trajectories from
our policy, computer gradient for each
of the log pi
of actions, sum them, multiply with
rewards, and then we can grade we can
get a gradient to apply
to improve our policy towards higher
rewards.
And so this full algorithm is called
reinforce. This is the acronym given by
Williams in 1992.
And this is
kind of our very first policy gradient
method.
And sometimes it's also referred to as
the vanilla policy gradient. It's quite
simple as you see. You start by
initializing your policy, you evaluate
an estimate of the gradients um
by collecting samples with the formula
we just derived.
Then you apply the gradients to your
weights and repeat the process by
collecting fresh data.
And here
the N is the number of of samples that
you collect. So obviously the the the
higher N the better cuz you will get a
more accurate estimation of your
expectation.
Um
in a perfect world you you can have like
infinite
samples to have an exact equality
and a perfect gradient, but of course
that's
not possible especially with robotics.
Um
So let's build some intuition for what
the gradient is actually doing.
Um the probably the easiest way is to
compare it to how the gradient for the
uh
uh behavior cloning formula looks like,
something we covered a few weeks
earlier.
So the behavior cloning gradient is just
the sum of the log probabilities of the
actions taken. So you're maximizing the
um
likelihood of whatever actions uh,
appeared in your data set collected by
the expert,
right? And so, all actions get the same
weight, um, no matter like if they were
good or if they led to good or bad
outcomes.
Um, the policy gradient here, uh, on the
top is is kind of the same thing it's
doing the same thing, um, but with the
difference that now, uh, each trajectory
is weighted by the total return.
Um, so, intuitively, um, you know, now
good trajectories get pushed up, uh, and
bad ones get pushed down.
All right.
Now, let's talk about, uh, causality.
So, we have derived a uh, reinforce of
our first kind of vanilla policy
gradient,
but, um,
now we can see like, you know, where it
starts to, uh, break down in the real
world.
Um, consider, um, this example for the
robot on, uh, on the top, right? So,
imagine the task is to, uh, reach
towards the or grasp the cup, and, um,
but it overshoots and gets a negative
reward in the end.
Uh, so, what does, uh, reinforce do? Um,
so, it will penalize every single action
in this trajectory, right? Including all
the good ones in the beginning of the
trajectory. Um, and that's wrong, right?
Because, you know, the first part maybe
like was good behavior, but then, you
know, like the the second half was bad.
Um,
and so, essentially like the what the
gradient will be telling is like, uh, to
the robot never move in that direction
cuz like it it led to a bad outcome,
right? So, it will be really, really
like difficult to learn this behavior,
um,
cuz you'll need like a lot a lot of
samples.
And so, essentially this this violates a
little bit the the causality, um,
the principles of causality,
um, in that in the physical world an
action taken at, uh, time step t uh, can
only affect rewards that happen either
at the same time or in the future, but
it cannot possibly, uh, be responsible
for uh, reward that already happened in
the past.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> So, the first kind of
uh fix that we can do to try to
alleviate this issue is
something called reward to go.
Um where instead of
multiplying the gradient of the action
at time T
by the sum of all rewards,
we only multiply it by
by [clears throat] the rewards from T
until the end of the episode.
Um
And so, this way
we're not changing the expected value of
our gradient, but we are reducing
significantly also the variance
and kind of trying to address this
overshooting
example.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, so with this we have fixed
causality, but there is another problem
of this reinforced method that is the
the high variance that I kind of
mentioned right now.
Um so, imagine that now we have like
these two
trajectories
where one is the same that overshoots,
but
we get like a reward of 99 and the other
one is like a perfect trajectory and
gets a reward of
a 101.
And so,
um
effectively like this um the signal
between these two trajectories now um is
like 101 - 99. It's that's two, right?
And that's like the actual information
content in like what's the difference
between these two behaviors in terms of
rewards.
Um but in reinforced like we will be
computing the gradient scaled by 99 and
101. So, like your optimizer will be
seeing this this great like this massive
gradient updates
Um where the the true signal is
essentially only 2% of like all all all
of this.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so the rest is just noise making your
training like very unstable.
Um
so
um
what we can do here
Yeah, so sorry. Here here you can see
the what I just mentioned.
Okay, so we've identified a problem,
right?
In that just like with this vanilla
formulation
reinforce can't distinguish
good
from bad trajectories when the returns
are large and similar.
Um so the fix for this is quite simple.
We can subtract a baseline B from the
reward to go to center our rewards. Um
that's the only change to the formula
really happening here.
Everything else stays the same and
>> [clears throat]
>> now we are waiting each action log
probability by the reward to go minus B
instead of the raw reward to go.
Um
and what happens now in our case is that
essentially now we are subtracting B
equals 100. Um
so that would be our the average
and now
the reward for our first trajectory
would be minus one and the one for the
second one would be plus plus one. And
now the gradient does exactly what we
would like it to do which is that it
suppresses the overshooting behavior
on the one hand and reinforces the good
the perfect reach behavior, right? So
that's really like what ideally we want
to be doing.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> now you might be also asking like well
this sounds a bit like cheating. Like,
what are we doing here like introducing
some random like
constants into the formula? Um no. So,
we are not We are not cheating here
because um in principle, like
if you are subtract a constant, B, this
doesn't change the expected value of the
gradient at all. Um so, it's kind of
like
zero bias operation, but it helps
enormously to reduce the high variance
problem.
Um
Okay, so we've been writing this this
policy gradient with now this reward to
go minus the baseline to reduce the
variance. Um and we said that, you know,
B could be like the mean reward, a
constant that that we subtract to reduce
the variance. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> but if we look at this more carefully,
like what are we actually computing?
Right? So,
it's kind of summing up all the rewards
from time step T onwards, right? So,
everything
that's happening after the current
action. And we are taking the
expectation over all the trajectory
sampled from our policy.
And this is actually, if you remember,
like the definition of a Q function.
Right?
Which is the expected sum of the future
rewards uh
um
>> [clears throat]
>> given that you are in a in a state ST,
and then you take your the action AT,
and follow your policy afterwards.
So, essentially,
um this is very interesting, the reward
to go um is a Monte Carlo estimate of
your Q function. Uh so, one noisy
sample, essentially.
Um
So, what we've been actually computing
all all the time is kind of like this
noisy estimate of the Q function
uh minus the baseline, right?
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> so
now that we have realized that, if we
combine this with our baseline idea, we
get what is called the advantage
function, A of P of SA.
Um,
so
what you think about, um,
like, how does this What is actually
this doing? So, um,
if Q pi is is the score that you expect
if you take a specific action A,
then V of pi is the score you expect on
average from this state ST just by
following your current policy.
Um, so the what the advantage is is
trying to answer is how much better is
it to take
action A from ST.
>> [snorts]
>> Um, and if you plug this back into the
policy gradient
formula,
um, you can see that now the positive
advantage means that the actions
was better than our average expectation,
so it it will increase its probability.
A negative advantage means that, um,
it was worse than our average
expectation, so we will decrease it.
Okay, so here's our latest and most
refined policy gradient formulation on
the top.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> and it has the causality and the
baselines,
but it has still kind of like one
practical issue that we mentioned in the
first kind of like, uh, reinforce
algorithm slide.
Um, right, that the trajectories are
only valid if,
uh, they are collected by the current,
uh,
policy, right?
Um,
so this is like not super practical for
us roboticists, right? Because we
already know that collecting data with
real robots is, you know, very costly
and you have to like
uh robots break, motors break, and so
forth. And so, if, you know, like once
you collect some data, like and you do
like one gra- gradient update, you have
to throw away your data and like collect
again. Like this is super inefficient,
right? It might be great for, you know,
in simulation or where it's like easy to
to collect a lot of data, but ideally
uh
we would like to um
be more sample efficient and maybe even
like do multiple gradient steps um
on the same data, right?
Um
All right. So, the challenge is clear.
Uh we want to avoid throwing away our
data. Um we want to um
make uh our policy gradient uh algorithm
a little bit more off-policy. How can we
do this?
Uh for this, we can turn into uh
important sampling,
uh which is a technique used to estimate
expectations under one distribution
uh when you only have access to samples
uh from a different distribution.
Um in our case, we want to compute uh
our expectation over a target
distribution p of x, uh but we are stuck
with uh samples. So, this would be our
new uh kind of uh policy. Um but in our
case, um we only have access to uh
samples from q of x, which is uh data
collected with our old policy.
Um
So, to do this,
um how we can write uh the expectation
as an integral,
we can use the same uh multiply by one
trick from the previous derivation um to
add the term um q of x uh divided by q
of x
uh inside the integral here on the the
on the right.
And um
now by rearranging the terms there, you
can uh put it into a more useful
um form, an expectation over a samples
from Q. Um I don't have a pointer, but
um
and um this means that now we can simply
uh weigh uh weigh our function uh
f of x um by the uh ratio of um
p of x uh divided by uh q of x.
Um so this means that now we can our
robot can use our old samples um
provided we weight them by the
probability
uh of that sample under the new policy
divided by uh its probability under the
old uh policy. Um one thing uh to note
here is that this thing only works if Q
has a non-zero support uh to remain
unbiased. Um
because as you can see, if we divided by
uh if like Q zero is like zero, uh then
like this uh
uh will not be uh defined. This
division.
And so also intuitively, like this
important sampling will work best if
both distributions are not too far away.
Uh not like the case I plotted here
where there is like
they're uh very very different.
Cool. Uh how does this look like uh in
practice in terms of uh math?
So
uh this is kind of like our RL objective
now with importance sampling.
>> [snorts]
>> And um
how does this look like in practice? So
uh we can uh start by inserting our
trajectory distribution formula using
the chain rule. Uh and uh substitute it
uh
uh for for the old uh and new policy.
Uh now we know that both policies will
have the same uh initial state and the
same uh
uh transition probabilities. Uh so, we
can cancel them out as they're operating
in the same MDP.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh and so now uh we are left with
essentially the the ratio uh of products
uh of the policy probabilities and uh
and this is as I said before quite
useful because we don't always have the
the dynamics of the world.
Uh
and so this way we can now evaluate this
importance weights.
Now then um
the next question is how do we derive uh
the gradient of this?
Um
because
uh in our gradient we still seem to be
sampling trajectories from the new
policy
uh and not the old one, right? So, here
like we
uh in the the gradient we still are like
sampling the the new the new policy.
Um
so now we can use the derivation uh we
did uh two slides ago for the
expectation of the importance sampling
uh and simply plug in those terms into
the formula.
Um and now um
the important uh trick here is that this
now changes. Now we are we have an
expectation over the old policy. So,
this is the the data that we have,
right?
Um
and so uh we expand now the uh
importance weights with the product uh
we derived in the previous slide.
And um this is still like a little bit
troublesome uh because it is exponential
in in the
uh in the horizon T. Um so,
this means that if, you know, imagine
uh that all our importance terms are
less than one. So, if we you multiply
many many numbers um like if T is very
long and you have many uh small numbers
and you multiply them,
um then their their product will go uh
exponentially uh fast uh to zero.
Uh meaning that your variance will grow
also uh infinite uh to go to infinity
exponentially fast.
Um
Exactly. So, this you know, this term is
a little bit troublesome uh cuz it can
be quite unstable with exploding
gradients and so forth.
Um in practice, we often consider
expectations over time steps instead of
uh over trajectories.
Um
So,
this is uh what we do. Um and we often
um
when we decompose this joint
distribution
uh of pi s and a,
uh we get the action ratio and the state
ratio.
And uh while we can easily calculate our
action ratio from our network, um we
cannot do this for the state ratio.
Um because we would need to know uh the
global dynamics uh of the environment
again, which we don't have, right?
Um
So, in practice, this often is
approximated by one, uh which is uh um
kind of an approximation that algorithms
now like TRPO and PPO do uh by forcing
the updates to be small. But in essence,
um this gives us kind of our final form
uh for
um
that you see in the bottom, um the
important weights uh reduce uh reduces
to just a ratio of action probabilities
uh of the new policy and the uh old
policy.
>> [clears throat]
>> And again, it's just an approximation
and it will only work if they are like
close enough.
Uh so, here is how the full algorithm
look likes in practice. Um,
uh in practice it's
not too different from like the
reinforce algorithm we just saw a few
slides ago.
But now the key difference is that
instead of
collecting and updating
collecting data and updating once
you now can
collect once and perform multiple
gradient updates.
Of course like the you know so you can't
do this like indefinitely. You cannot
like
do multiple gradient updates before
collecting again
because this would push your
distributions too far and then like the
ratio
would not work.
So
we established that the important
sampling breaks down when the support
set is zero
right when the new policy
by theta
prime assigns probability to action
state pairs that the old policy for
example never took.
So what can we do about this?
One kind of easy solution is to add an
entropy bonus to the policies gradient
objective.
So
the idea is that we don't want
our old policy to become too
deterministic
so that it assigns zero probability to
regions of the action space.
>> [clears throat]
>> So we want to really to encourage the
policy to kind of spread out
to reduce the chance of um
of hitting the the zero support in the
first place.
And so [snorts]
that's essentially what we're doing
here.
So we can add like this kind of entropy
term to the loss
Uh, and uh, then we can um, have this
temperature parameter that controls like
how much weight we give to this entropy.
Uh, so um, the larger it is, the more
like spread out uh, it will be and um,
if you go closer to
uh, zero, it will be like kind of more
greedy.
Um, there are kind of two different ways
how you can implement this depending on
uh, the action space of your um, of your
robot. Uh, if it's uh, discrete actions,
then you can use the kind of standard
uh, Shannon entropy.
Um,
and for continuous actions, uh, you can
uh, use a differential uh, entropy for a
Gaussian policy.
Uh, and here uh, D is uh, the
dimensionality for uh, your action
space. So, if it's like a 7 DOF, then it
it will be a 7.
Um, okay, we could talk more about this,
but maybe let's move on for time.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay. So,
we've talked a a little bit about um,
uh, that um, the important sampling only
works when the old and new policies are
close.
But, what happens if they're not, right?
Uh, if we as I said, if we perform
multiple uh, gradient uh, updates and
then you know, the uh, it goes
uh, from the same batch to but then the
policy changes too much before we
collect new data.
Uh, and here is like kind of like uh, a
specific uh, kind of
failure mode example uh, you can see
uh, where
um,
imagine [clears throat] that you have
some uh, action that was unlikely under
the old policy. Uh, uh, but uh, it gets
a high reward, so the new policy gives
it like higher weight. Oh, sorry, higher
probability. Um, and then uh,
the importance weight uh, will
essentially become very large like let's
say 20 uh, in this case.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so this will be really bad.
Sorry. Uh because now your gradient
estimate will explode essentially if
like the importance weight is like very
large.
So one solution
um to this problem [clears throat] is to
constrain
uh the policy so it doesn't change too
much uh during those multiple gradient
steps that you're taking.
Uh one way how you can implement this is
by adding a KL divergence constraint.
Uh so which measures how
>> [snorts]
>> Sorry. [clears throat] How close um
uh two probability distributions are.
And um essentially like this will now
penalize um uh the new policy if it uh
tries to assign let's say zero uh uh a
probability of zero to an action that
the old policy took.
Uh because the old policy uh data is
kind of our ground truth data
uh that ensures um that we have support
for uh the new policies actions.
And
this is essentially um
what uh the algorithm called trust
region policy optimization uh TRPO
implemented in 2015.
Um the key benefit uh so it's like
essentially the the we're maximizing the
um our policy gradient formulation we
derived before subject to uh the KL
divergence, right? And um
uh I will not go too much into details.
We could do like uh talk a lot about
this, but um the key benefits from TRPO
are um that uh it provides uh a
theoretical guarantee um that each
update will improve uh or not uh worsen
uh
the true performance uh of JP uh pi.
Um but kind of the the downside here is
that
uh
this KL constraint requires computing
the official information matrix, uh
which is a matrix of second derivatives
with respect to the KL divergence
uh uh of the KL divergence with respect
to the policy parameters. Uh and this is
computationally very heavy. Uh it's it's
like uh n squared uh for the memory uh
and then um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh
uh n cubed uh for uh compute. And so,
there are like some approximations with
uh conjugate gradients and so on. Um but
in general, like it's kind of like very
difficult uh to scale.
Uh even like uh for deep networks, uh
you need to even further approximations.
Uh
um
So, it's like not
that popular nowadays.
But still, uh
you know, you can see a really
compelling also like uh robotics
applications even here from ETH uh uh
how, you know, TRPO was used to uh to
train like a quadruped locomotion um
simple simple to real. And you can see
uh
very nice uh zero-shot generalization
examples.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh and this is now a quadruped that can
uh navigate challenging terrain. Um
uh step over obstacles.
Um and also like um uh do locomotion
over surfaces that uh
it might not have seen during training.
Um so, like it actually works.
All right. So, TRPO has great guarantees
on but we kind of like hate the
computational cost. Uh so, the question
is can we get that stability without
this expensive like second-order math?
Uh
and kind of the
uh
a more popular algorithm or that because
it's a bit more easier to implement is
called proximal policy optimization.
Um where the key idea is like what if we
can just clip the importance ratio
instead of constraining it with the KL
divergence.
Um
so
kind of like this is how
how now the our policy gradient update
looks like and essentially you can see
like we are constraining this to be like
inside some interval
and we are
taking the minimum um of of these two uh
clips.
>> [snorts]
>> Um and because now this is like a simple
first-order method like it scales
linearly
and works perfectly with a standard
optimizers like Adam
and this kind of like scalability um
is exactly why
PPO is is the backbone for many uh
um for for training like large language
models
with like RRLHF or like GRPO and so
forth.
Um the trade-off that we're making here
is that we don't have a monotonic
improvement guarantee anymore
but
and it's still near on-policy. Uh so we
still need quite a bit of samples to
learn PPO.
Uh so it's quite reliable
and quite stable
across many different domains and
applications but we are it's still
mostly uh uh
fundamentally near on-policy method.
Um in robotics
Oh, this is not playing.
Yeah, in robotics one famous application
of PPO
was done by Open AI 2019
where they taught this kind of really
Dexel Shadow hand that has like 24
degrees of freedom
to solve
a Rubik's Cube.
Um, and this was again also like a sim
to real
kind of approach where they did a lot of
domain randomization in simulation.
Uh, but then, you know,
you can see it's like it can work across
many perturbations even like if it has
like tied fingers.
Um,
uh, and yeah, maybe like one thing
to note here is that
so here PPO
didn't receive like camera observations
as input
like a state input, but essentially they
had a more modular approach where they
first had like kind of perception
uh, network to extract
like the position and orientation of the
cube
which was then fed to PPO.
All right. Um,
okay, so here is the full objective of
PPO.
And you can see a lot of things that we
have covered today come together in like
this single formula. So, there are like
three terms, right? So, first is the
clipped uh, uh, the the clipped
surrogate objective we just derived for
PPO. Um, this is an actor the actor loss
that is updating our policy parameters
and it's trying to maximize the
advantage while keeping
the importance ratio in a in a safe
range.
Uh, the second term is the value
function loss
and
this is essentially a critic and it's
kind of being trained simultaneously to
give us better estimates of the
advantage function.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> remember like the advantage function
requires
the value of pi, right? Of the states.
And so the better our critic is, the
lower the variance of
of our advantage estimates will be and
the more stable our policy. And the
third term is the entropy bonus we
discussed earlier, keeping the kind of
policy from collapsing to a
deterministic solution and maintaining
exploration.
And so here like the the key thing here
is
that this is now what we call an actor
critic formulation or architecture.
And this is kind of very nice because
now we are combining the the best of
both worlds of like policy gradients
approaches to give us like
you know like direct optimization for
the behavior we care about. As well as
the value the value based methods that
give we're using to give us
low variance baseline through our
critic.
And so as I said like this gives rise to
this family of algorithms called actor
critic methods, right? And the actor is
the policy
and the critic is the value function.
And
they are
yeah, trained together.
Um
Yeah, maybe like one thing to note here
is that
the critic is
learns via
TD updates. So meaning that it
bootstraps from its own estimates to
next time step rather than waiting for
the full trajectory return, which is a
limitation that we had if we only used
policy gradients for our actor, right?
We would have to wait until the end of
the episode. Um
And so this means that now this is quite
much more sample efficient than using
this Monte Carlo returns. Um at the cost
of the small like uh bias that you're
bootstrapping bias.
Um and maybe for robotics uh
also interesting is um that
uh
you can often uh train the critic by
using privileged information. Uh because
you don't use the critic at test time.
So especially if you're using like a
simulator environment or or so, you can
use like additional
in state information or privileged
information for your critic uh to reduce
the variance, right? To get you like
better advantage estimates.
Uh and then you know like a test time
you throw the critical away, so it
doesn't really matter. But it kind of
help a lot your your your trading.
Um
Yeah.
Um Okay, I need to wrap up soon. So
Yeah. Okay, so the last the last family
of algorithms uh we will uh uh briefly
touch upon today is the soft actor
critic. Right? Because um this kind of
like closes the the loop, right? Uh we
have started like uh with very on-policy
methods and we've been trying to get
more and more off-policy to like be more
sample efficient and use more uh
previous data, right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh and so soft actor critic is kind of
the answer to that. It's a fully
off-policy actor critic algorithm that
trains the critic uh on a replay buffer
uh
just like DQN um in the lecture that we
covered in the lecture before.
Um so the actor has uh kind of these two
terms. Uh the exploration um
uh bonus that we saw before and the
exploitation
uh which like just answers if I were to
do this action today, like how many uh
points would I get, right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Um and then
like um there is kind of this this this
uh push and pull between uh these two,
right?
Um
and then uh the critic loss is kind of a
standard uh TD um
uh error. So, the square difference
between uh what the critic currently
thinks uh a past state action pair was
worth and what it uh
uh what it should think based on the
actual uh
reward received uh plus the discounted
value of the next state.
And um the crucially also here um there
is also this uh entropy uh term. Uh that
means that uh you know, we want um
states uh that lead uh or we benefit we
we push for states that lead to higher
rewards uh
and also give you many different ways uh
to achieve it. Right? So, this will get
like uh
uh uh
uh pushed.
And the key idea here is that the actor
pulls all states from the replay buffer,
but asks now the current policy and not
the old one what action it would take uh
here today.
Right? So, the critic asks kind of
as a learned simulator
um estimating how much reward uh
the new action would have gotten in in
the old state,
even though it never actually has seen
this state action combination. So,
that's really kind of the the key uh
here.
Um
yeah.
There is one remaining problem. I will
not go into too much details. Um
this is pertaining um to how to uh back
propagate to the sampling uh process um
where you can use like a standard
reparameterization uh trick uh for
Gaussians, for example, also very used
in variational inference and VAEs and so
on.
Um, so, yes, but I'm getting out of
time.
Uh, and there are also some real-world
demonstrations of um,
uh, SAC
on a real robot, uh, real robots from
the original papers,
uh, both from legal stacking, uh,
quadruped manipulation, or also
dexterous hands.
And, um,
yeah.
To conclude, uh, today we started with
reinforce. Uh, it's kind of a very
direct way to optimize a policy.
Uh, we saw, you know, it has some
limitations, the vanilla, uh, version of
it
of reinforce, and we started to fix
those by adding causality and and
baselines to kind of fight the high
variance problem. Uh, and then we moved
on to, uh, advantage, uh, functions
to make our, um,
>> [clears throat]
>> to make our, uh, rewards relative to
each other
rather than absolute.
Uh, then we kind of hit the on-policy
wall. Uh, we, uh, cuz we are still kind
of requiring to collect new, uh, fresh
data, um, for every gradient step. So,
we introduced important sampling, uh, to
allow us to, uh, take multiple gradient
steps, uh, on a single batch of data.
Um, and we also explored, uh, adding
entropy regularization, um, to ensure
the robot, uh, never stops exploring,
and we, uh, still have like, uh,
non-zero support for important sampling.
Uh, and then we also, uh, looked at
different ways, um, to,
uh, constrain the change between the
policies, uh,
with a KL divergence,
uh, and also with PPO, the simplified
clipping, um, to kind of like bound how
much, uh, the policy can drift in a
single update. And finally, uh, we, uh,
reached, um,
soft actor-critic.
where we train critic
fully off policy
with a replay buffer similar to what we
saw last
lecture with DQN.
And we we see that this kind of achieves
the highest sample efficiency
from all our methods that we talked
about today and this is also why it's
still today a very popular algorithm for
also real robotics.
Yes, with this thank you for your
attention.
>> [applause]